uh somewhere against we do have a
youngster that is currently on four out
of four from the last four games
certainly on our role is abhimanyu
mishra the youngest grand master in the
world with christian carrillo thank you
alejandro yes we are here indeed with
avi manu i remind you first of all
congratulations four out of four what
did you do after uh that second round
loss yeah i mean i started to do more
tactics like i was able to like finish
what i was trying to do after that was
like finish my opening preparation
before that day itself after coming back
from the game and then just do like a
like a lot of tactics and that's helping
a lot because like they're like for
example this game against my first game
which i won in a row that my game gets
raja this queen bee queen is seven idea
like this queen 28 idea
i wasn't actually there was a similar
tactic that i was doing on some website
that i wasn't able to find this and that
definitely helped me after figuring the
tactic out to help me find this one in
the game and how did you deal with that
difficult moment psychologically what
did you tell yourself after that second
round loss or what did your coach uh
tell you sure
so i just told myself okay
loss has happened to everyone i mean
there's not a single person in the world
who has not come without a lot without a
loss and yeah i just they're so they're
i can't just ruin the whole tournament
just because of one game so let's just
keep playing and see how it goes well it
definitely worked out and today's game
was kind of wild he played this move
bishop to f5 at some point and we were
just completely shocked how did you
react to that move yeah bishop five i
was very confused about i was
considering bishop takes g6 and like h6
g6 e takes f6 and
it's very messy but i i'm honestly not
sure what's going on like rookie 6
there's f5
and i think yeah black is still under
some pressure here because rook takes f6
fg6
rook g6 there's rook d7
and yeah maybe maybe black is still fine
here after say rook g3 rook b7 but it's
not entirely clear but it's it's white
who has uh the much more pleasant
position
yeah
right well so bishop f5 was your initial
reaction
i was very confused i saw knight d5 did
you even consider bishop five before he
played it no not really
because i saw okay anyways i have this
knight d5 move so knight d5 and now it's
knight e3 is always a threat and he
played this queen f2 idea after after
knight d5 queen f2 i think it's like
with white either you have to play queen
after a queen e2 because
other than that 93 is a threat and gf5
so queen f2 gf5 knight of five
and yeah i checked with him after the
game he said he missed the smooth rookie
six
right and the idea of rookie six is i'm
basically doing the same thing as king
of jade like
generally in this kind of situation kh8
is a much more logical move but after
kha knight d6 white white gets uh an
exchange back and it's
maybe black is still better somehow but
i really don't like it
yeah i don't think black's better yeah
yeah yeah so rookies is an important
resource but he found some kind of nice
moves rook d4 also yeah this was very
strange actually after rook d4 i spent
like 10 minutes but
maybe there's a win for black but i just
i just couldn't see it because i mean
rook d1 is coming next yeah and the
weird part is like i'm up a piece my
king isn't under immediate fire but the
thing is
he just piles up on this 95 and i but i
don't have a move i don't see how i can
defend it queen f3 93 was also possible
at some point yeah so we got to this
position and it felt that you took on d6
and yeah one play
it has an extra pawn but
yeah still
not so clear right yes instead of rook
takes the uh instead of queen xd6 i mean
during the game i consider knight f6
also
maybe it's somehow stronger objectively
but i really couldn't tell what was
going on after g4 yeah it's just a mess
because the main point of knight f6 is
after d7 you can uh i think you can take
d7
rook d7 rook g2
uh queen xg2 bishop takes g2 rook case
f7
and now you have this place move bishop
d5 yeah
and if we're playing d5 queen you want
queen e4
or ch2 queen f2 queen f3 whatever same
thing
but after yeah
and i but after g4 instead of d7 i just
couldn't tell what was going on for the
reason that like
my king is also extremely weak and d7
queen h4 is a very legitimate threat
and i saw like two moves here if queen
b3
there's king h2 and he defends the ch3
pawn and if rookies g4 d7 is winning for
white
and instead of queen v3 queen c5 which i
thought was
uh just because if black consolidates
here i think he is going to be winning
soon because 94 rook d8 if you you'll
win this d6 pawn right but i was worried
about say d7 and say rook d or queen h4
and
i just
i couldn't tell what was going on and
like i had a few minutes before time
control like 10 moves to make so
i just chose not to go into this because
in the game i was
like in the game it's minimally it's
like not a winning advantage for black
but i'm
i have no risk at all were you surprised
by his decision to exchange the queens
yeah
after
yeah because i think he missed the
smooth rook g3
which was a great like yeah rookie seven
rook g3 and black is just like winning
because i bring my book to b3 kingdoms
to g6 i play h5 h4 bring my king to f4
like white is just tied down
like after king f2 i think black has
this nice move rook d five right
all right you mean king f2 right now
yeah i can't
and if like rook b3 or rogue d3 i like
both of them are really great because
ideas i wrote d3 is that you cannot play
rook b7 because of b3
king is is impossible due to root b3
again but also rook d2 right
yeah after
yeah end of k1 i can just like play king
g8 and
the thing is i kind of gain a tempo and
or maybe even h5 first
and
by making sure that this king cannot
come in to defend b2 his rook is always
going to be tied down to the defensive
v2 pawn and yeah it's very difficult for
him to defend here if if it's possible i
think it's just lost is just a great
piece to um on b3 is going to be doing
everything defending and attacking so
yeah certainly a bad concept there for
him but you must be feeling thrilled uh
there are four in a row uh great chances
to be actually tied for first place uh
going into the seventh round as we think
that uh chris is actually losing his
game uh did you feel that you had good
chances to win the tournament before it
started
yeah before the start of it i was this
was my goal to come here and try to win
this tournament whether it works or not
i wasn't exactly sure but i was just
trying my best to win this
well you're certainly are on the way a
nice few games you put a strong there
together uh abby manuel good luck in the
next few games thank you alejandro
all right let's take a look at what else
we have left
we are